the significance of the Good Friday
agreement's 25th anniversary is obvious
by who's been here and what's been said
supporting the people of Northern
Ireland protecting the peace preserving
the Belfast Good Friday agreement is a
priority
for Democrats and Republicans alike in
the United States we had a visit from
U.S President Joe Biden he encouraged
politicians in Northern Ireland to
restore power sharing address the Irish
parliament in Dublin and retrace his
ancestral roots
and tonight one of the driving forces
behind the Good Friday agreement Bill
Clinton is visiting too he'll be
addressing students alongside prime
minister Rishi sunak Senator George
Mitchell the man who brokered the
historic compromise will be in town too
I'm David Blevins senior Ireland
correspondent in Belfast and this is the
Sky News Daily
25 years on I've been speaking to one of
the leaders behind the Good Friday
agreement former Prime Minister Tony
Blair his pragmatism helped push the
parties to one of the most historic
peace agreements ever a day like today I
mean it's not a day for sort of sound
bite really
um we can leave those at home but I feel
that I feel the hand of history on our
shoulder
Tony Blair people talk a lot about the
spirit of
1998 how would you define the spirit of
1998 when the agreement was struck
there was just a
a huge moment of Hope
um
it's it's very hard for people
now to to just think back on those times
and a lot of people are either very
young or not even born at the time of
the Good Friday agreement but you know
when I was growing up to a degree
probably when you were growing up
the troubles as we call them where the
thing that defined Northern Ireland
defined its politics
um every day you would you would hear
stories on the news of fresh acts of
terrorism or violence and killing
assassination
it was it and and the the Northern
Ireland itself was just
disfigured by by this unable to move
forward unable to create in Belfast the
the type of thriving City it is today so
it was a the signing of the agreement we
were probably naive to think it would
that would be it you know we'd sign the
agreement and I I always thought it was
going to be a process and not just an
event
but I mean it took us frankly another
almost 10 years to put it fully in place
was it fit or was there a strategy
it was a combination of the right
circumstances and and I think we had the
right strategy so we had a political
framework that made sense which was
republicanism and nationalism accepting
the Northern Ireland would remain a part
of the UK for as long as the majority of
people in Northern Ireland wanted it and
in return for that there had to be
reform of Institutions and proper
Justice and equality for for those
people that weren't unionist or
Protestant if you like so
um there was a political strategy at the
heart that made sense but also the
context the circumstances were such as
we approached the 21st century that
people people were exhausted and wanted
peace
in those crucial 24 hours or 48 Hours
perhaps leading up to the agreement are
there two or three moments in your mind
which you consider to be definitive that
you will always remember
well I remember all of the negotiation
because it stretched actually over three
days and it was agonizing because it was
constantly that the agreement was on and
then it was off I mean it was mostly off
by the way and the two things that stand
out for me are number one when I arrived
and
I remember Senator Mitchell George
Mitchell saying to me at the time look I
think this is hopeless and a lot of
people felt the same who were with me uh
and
right at the very end when we David
Trimble called me and said okay we can
we can go with this and then then we we
were out and away with it but during
those two between those two moments was
just
it's just unimaginably difficult when I
spoke to Bertie I heard last week he
shared how at one stage he met with
loyalist paramilitary leaders in
Northern Ireland in the days leading up
to the agreement were there
conversations you were involved in that
you've never spoken about in in the
run-up to the agreement yeah there was
quite a few very private and difficult
conversations
I mean the
the Loyalists David evine who sadly
passed away now is very important he was
a highly intelligent capable man and of
course we were constantly engaged with
the Republicans
and really part of it was
trying to
make sense of
the opposing narratives of why we had
reached this position and and then
trying to bridge the gap of trust that
there was
between those two opposing narratives
and two opposing factions and in that
the the engagement with the I mean
frankly the people of violence was it
was important
and it gave it gave me a sense also of
what was possible because I could see
after that engagement that even though
there were these completely different
views as to how we got here nonetheless
there was a there was a a joint
determination to try and get out of
where we were if possible you talk about
David Irvine we hear a lot about The Man
Behind the agreement Tony Blair bertia
Herron Senator Mitchell John Hume David
Trimble
but there was a woman of course who
played an instrumental role uh momolam
how significant was her contribution as
Northern Ireland secretary so I think
the the most contribution was was
immense because
of what she represented
not because of Any individual items she
negotiated but because she she was a
complete culture shock and you know I
mean for those of us
who had lived through successive
very conservative looking very
conservative Big C and small C looking
men who who were secretaries of State
for Northern Ireland I mean you know a
lot of them decent vote but you know
they they were archetypal British
politicians and suddenly in steps Mo
um who was
the complete opposite
of an archetypal politician I mean it
did have a it had its own
impact on showing people that we were in
a different world and in particular I
think for the Republican and nationalist
Community it showed them there was
another side to Britain and that maybe
Britain was changing as a country which
of course we were
um and those in many ways are
representative of that so she her her
contribution was that was that was part
of what created the context in which
people felt well you know maybe the
times are changing maybe it's different
maybe we can give this a go how
important
was the phone call from President
Clinton during the night would you have
got over the line without the
intervention of the president I think
Bill Clinton was really important
because he
won because he was President of the
United States so that matters you know
whatever side of the fence you're on in
this dispute people listen to the
president of the United States the
Republicans have to listen to them the
unionists respect the presidency so he
was important for that
reason but he was important more because
he had this extraordinary political
intuition so I I literally I mean I I
would phone him at any time of the day
and night and he'd be completely
switched on and the thing was
you didn't have to explain the politics
of the situation to him he got it
instinctively immediately and therefore
it wasn't just that he was calling
people but he was calling people with a
lot of craft and what in in what the
call entailed and the way he put things
and framed them for the different side
so he was you know he was extremely
important in it and I was really lucky
to have him as a as a partner
do you appreciate the magnitude of what
was achieved on Good Friday 1998 more
now than you did even then I suppose
what I'm asking is
do you feel the hand of History a little
heavier on your shoulder no I I think
the thing is at the time
I was aware it was important
but straight afterwards I was due to go
for a family holiday in Spain
and it was only when I was literally
with my family and my kids were still
young at the time walking down
Street in in Cordova where we've gone to
to stay with friends
and people would stop me you know
Spanish people would stop me in the
street and start talking about it then I
started to think
this is actually not just a big deal for
the UK it's it's a global globally
significant agreement and then
in later times as you particularly
having been involved also in the
israeli-palestinian issue you realize
actually there aren't I can't think
really of another major peace process
that's been brought to a to a clear
fruition
so you know it it I think now I'm I'm
probably more aware of it than
than but you know you've got to keep it
the whole time and you've got to
preserve it and it's still it's still
got its fragility and hasn't passed it
celebrated 25 years later is it time to
think about something other than
mandatory Coalition for example
I don't think the time's right for that
I think you've still got to have a The
Good Friday agreement took account of
the very specific circumstances of of
Northern Ireland and those specific
circumstances are still there you know
you can see it in the politics now I do
believe in time by the way there is a
new generation coming through in
Northern Ireland that that will think
less about whether you're a republican a
nationalist or a unionist and we'll
think more about
what's the best economic future how do
we you know how do we raise our children
in peace and security with opportunity
so it may be in time things change but
at the moment no I think the basic
Contours of the agreement are still
necessary to to maintain stability you
you talk about that coming in time
obviously the agreement to some extent
silence the guns and the bombs are
largely silenced them but hasn't
produced the reconciliation that was
hoped for
how disappointed are you about that
it takes a long time for people to
reconcile
I mean all of the people who are engaged
at the top of Northern Ireland politics
now are still people with the memory the
long memory of the past
and and you know of course you've got to
be I was always very clear with people
about the Good Friday agreement
the central question United Kingdom or
United Islands unresolved
so that in itself
will cause some tension and then you
know more recently we've had the brexit
issue in the Northern Ireland protocol
and so on so it's it's not surprising to
me
I mean I'd like to see it happen over
time and hopefully over time it will but
I think
you know for those of us who who grew up
living through that period I mean the
these distrusts go very very deep and
reconciling them is that is the work
probably of several Generations
you say it's unresolved how capable are
the political leaders of today of
grasping
the nuances of Northern Ireland and
helping to resolve it
you see
The View
I had and this is where
you know without going into the all the
bridge brexit divisions
Europe was important
because in a way with the Republic of
Ireland and and the UK both in Europe
together both working together in Europe
my view was always that one of the
things the Good Friday agreement did was
it just made the Border
less practically important
constitutionally significant but less
practically important
and the trouble is the brexit thing is
put it back on the agenda as a as an
issue of practicality because you now
it's the north-south border is the
external border of the European Union so
it's
I think
the best thing for political leaders
today
is to remember if they think the peace
has been a good thing
remember this one
principle which is actually a principle
about leadership it only came about
because of leadership
it only came about because there were
leaders prepared to be unpopular even
with their own Grassroots constituency
or part of it and it only came about
because there were Leaders with the
creativity and the imagination to say
whatever the obstacles we're going to
find their way through and they found it
so that's the
the there are many different lessons of
the Good Friday or Belfast agreement
and one of them
is about leadership not specifically
Northern Ireland or specifically the
conflict but about leadership and that's
what I would urge the people who are in
positions of political leadership today
to to reflect upon I have just one final
question when Senator Mitchell uttered
those 19 words I'm pleased to announce
that the two governments and the
political parties of Northern Ireland
have reached agreement
how did you feel in that moment
I always say to people there are so few
moments in politics where you you are in
a celebratory mood
so few moments that you remember those
and remember them for all of your life
and this was one of them perhaps
certainly
yeah the most the most joyful moment I
ever had in my time in office
oh
my thanks to Tony Blair and to you for
listening to the Sky News Daily with me
David Blevins
if you want to hear more from Northern
Ireland and the Republic do scroll back
in this feed and listen to our other
episodes including where we ask why do
so many U.S presidents like to say I'm
Irish
foreign